good morning Hank it's Tuesday so due to
tornadoes and broken airplanes in a
chain of events too complicated for my
exhausted brain to unravel I have
visited airports nine times in the past
100 hours and I am very tired and
recently I unexpectedly found myself
alone on a train in New York the city
where Brotherhood 2.0 began for me and
also the city where earlier this year we
played a sold-out show at Carnegie Hall
a dependent clause that I will get tired
of saying when never so anyway there I
wasn't the Train blinking a lot because
my eyes desperately wanted to be closed
and I kept thinking about this tumblr
message I had received earlier from a
middle school student who is currently
attending the very same school that I
attended in seventh grade and who has
one of the same teachers that I had the
message read in part his name redacted
and I were talking and she told me that
you were a quiet unique and miserable
boy in middle school she also told me
that you were bullied because of your
awesomeness it didn't feel like
awesomeness at the time of course at the
time I was just miserable I mean Hank
you'll note that this teacher didn't say
I was a good student because I wasn't I
wasn't nearly a nerd I was at least I
felt like I was a stupid nerd which is
like the worst kind of combo I take that
back Pizza combos are the worst kind of
compost they are an insult to pizza but
anyway I almost ever think about middle
school now Hank but the message really
forced me to remember it and also I was
on a train which inherently makes you
kind of nostalgic so yeah it's true that
I was miserable and that I was bullied
in fact I would often fantasize about
hurting my brewery's are holding a gun
to their heads and making them apologize
making them feel as scared and powerless
as I felt but of course that isn't the
way forward I realize now that the
people who bullied me were not evil they
were kids living with their own fear in
pain some of whom were dealing with
trauma and abuse that I never even could
have imagined
now that doesn't justify their behavior
but it does help me to understand that
it really wasn't about me their
treatment of me was not a reflection of
my value as a human being and while it
was very difficult for me to feel
anything but miserable in those days in
retrospect I survived middle school
because many people in fact were quite
kind to me my parents teachers fellow
nerds and even popular strangers who
wouldn't stand for bully
we decide collectively what kind of
behavior is acceptable and while the
word of the flies would have you believe
that like adolescents always descend
into mere cruelty my experience of
social orders has been much more
complicated I've found that sometimes
often even kids are capable of
tremendous kindness and generosity in
fact that's been the hallmark of the
nerdfighter community for more than
seven years now and I'm proud to be a
nerdfighter in part because I wish so
much that I could have been one in
seventh grade there are always
nerdfighters in our pants link in the
doobly-doo who will listen to you if you
will also listen back and that is truly
awesome right so anyway there was this
moment on stage at Carnegie Hall during
the soundcheck when John darn yelled the
mountain goats said into the mic this is
a message for 16-year old me not only
did you survive you are playing piano at
Carnegie Hall now I'm not going to tell
you that like everyone who has a tough
time as a kid ends up at Carnegie Hall
but the idea that those years have to be
the best of your life is just ridiculous
so to the young woman who wrote me to
myself stranded far from home in an
endless string of airports and train
rides I call up the great Robert Frost
quote the only way out is through you
will get through I will get through Hank
I'll see you hopefully from Indianapolis
nonprofit